i have always been passionate about
learning new things and improving my
teaching skills
about five years ago i realized that i
have a gap in my knowledge and to fill
the gap i needed to upskill myself i
chose imprint of my upskilling partner
because of its comprehensive curriculum
and its connection with purdue
university
hi my name is carlos linares
i live in lexington in the city of
kentucky in the united states
i am an assistant professor at midway
university and i hold a
phd in management human resources and
literature
i decided to opt for the post graduation
program in business analysis from
simpler which has helped me a lot in my
professional and personal life
i have been teaching even before i moved
to the united states several years ago
i tried to use excel while teaching
research classes
but
since i only had the basic knowledge
about it from other business
intelligence tools
it was very difficult for me at the
beginning
but
after completing this class and learning
how to use tools like
excel tableau power bi
power query properly i feel like
it has been a total game changer for me
now i apply these skills everywhere
which has also helped me a lot
in my yearly reviews
i submitted all my certificates to my
university and based on that
my university plans to develop a class
focus on business analysis starting in
fall 2023
and i am really excited
when i finally decide to go for an
online program i research a lot
and finally i chose simply learn and i
must say it has been
a wonderful experience
if you see how the business world is
changing now and skilling yourself is
quite essential to keep up with the
change everything works on numbers now
data is more valuable and important than
ever
so
i encourage you to keep learning
and keep growing